une plongée vers le titanic maintenant
une grande partie des six mille objets
remontés à la surface casseroles
chaussures valises sont réunis pour une
exposition à la cité des sciences à
paris laurence de cheikh abdel oulias
le titanic largue les amarres de
southampton pour son premier voyage 10
avril 1912
direction new york quatre jours plus
tard en heurtant un iceberg
l'insubmersible poule l'épave ne sera
localisé dans l'atlantique nord que 74
ans plus tard entre 1986 et l'an 2006
expéditions du sous marin le nautile
permettront de remonter près de 6000
objets les effets des passagers les
outils du navire ou la vaisselle de
première classe
françois cherche un nom dans la liste de
tous les passagers
celui de son père qui a survécu au
naufrage il jouait aux cartes et il a
entendu le choc
il a demandé un un petit garçon d'ouvrir
le hublot zoo vers les hublots ils ont
vu liesberg donc dès le début dès la
première seconde il savait ce que
c'était mais comme beaucoup de gens ils
pensaient que le bateau n'avait pas mené
après il a eu un doute quand il n'a pas
pouvoir parler au commandant le joyau du
titanic le grand escalier qui mène au
restaurant mais aussi des cabines de
troisième ou de première classe des
décors entièrement reconstituée tous
d'origine les objets eux ont été
restaurés
il ya certains objets qui sont vraiment
on a pu identifier leurs propriétaires
et donc c'est ce qui donne des
biographies de certains passagers qui
ont été reconstruits c'est ce qui est
très émouvant on peut suivre comme ça
l'avis les intentions de plusieurs
passagers rongé par les eaux à 3800
mètres de fond l'épave menace
aujourd'hui de s'effondrer complètement